mental health hacks to address anger uh
anger is a big one uh i used to be a
very angry person it was probably my
dominant emotion uh now my dominant
negative emotions probably paranoia but
i basically got rid of most of my anger
uh if not all of it and
it left just through the realization of
just the harm it was doing to me we're
not meant to be angry all the time in a
natural environment you'd be angry uh
you know once in a blue moon but now
thanks to news media and just the very
complex lives that we lead um you know
there's lots of aggressions and now
there's this whole thing called
microaggressions like god who even wants
to deal with that but
what you have to realize is that anger
hurts you first and foremost anger is
you credibly signaling getting ready to
signal violence because you're losing
control over the situation and so to do
that to prepare for violence uh whether
it's verbal or whether it's physical
you have to basically
you know release all these nasty
hormones and chemicals in your body to
tense you up for that fight-or-flight
response and you just can't run in that
all the time it burns you out you lose
your hair you know your skin will sag
you you know your your metabolism will
burn out um you know you'll have
digestive problems um there's a great
buddhist saying that someone is quoting
right now in my feed i use it all the
time so i just didn't want to say it
again but i'll say it again it's it's
anger is a hot coal that you hold in
your hand while you wait to throw it at
somebody and i think that is true you're
holding this hot coal and it's literally
burning you uh while you're trying to
figure out you know when and how hard am
i gonna throw it so the best way to get
rid of anger is not to say oh i'm not
going to be angry that kind never works
you just have to notice every time
you're angry how much is hurting you and
then eventually at some point you just
won't want it anymore and when you don't
want an emotion it doesn't really arrive
at the same intensity
[Music]
[Music]
you